vous savez qu'il va recevoir maintenant
c'est pas mais il ya une espèce de truc
super flottant quoi je pense que ça va
être quelqu'un d'important ouais ouais
je reçois henri d'orléans et
henri d'orléans bonsoir gad elmaleh jean
yanne laurent baffie caroline ducey je
voudrais lumière on doit on doit vous
êtes les comme henri d'orléans
monseigneur toujours la même enseigne
aurait pu si j'étais moins saignant ma
couille
non
mais c'est monseigneur c'est bien de
savoir si stéphane bern j'appelle
commandes
en fait c'est stéphane bern qui s'est
tous là dessus pas toujours pas toujours
mais là il va faire comment monseigneur
ses fans oui et jean claude gayssot qui
est ami avec le prince rainier le roi
albert ii de belgique qui vous appelle
commande le jamais rencontré c'est moi
qui avais raison qui rit oui c'est
monseigneur monseigneur que se
passe-t-il si on n'appelle pas monsieur
monseigneur non mais attendez arrivé en
liant et trucs cool c'est pas du tout
hein c'est vrai vous n'êtes pas du tout
c'est ce qui fait votre charme
d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas du tout
beagle pourquoi vous n'êtes ni région
yann monseigneur pourquoi je l'admiré
ouais mais parce que il est dérangé un
petit peu mais c'est ça qu'il faut dans
la ville et l'a gravement dérangé il m'a
dérangé mois déjà il ya 35 ans pour ça
que je suis comme ça c'est l'avenir à
rien c'est un double mètre ils vont
prendre une mesure non ça pue la nécro
la classant le césar d'honneur détours
pourquoi tu sais faire du bien
monseigneur voilà j'ai eu peur depuis la
mort de votre père en 1999 êtres l'aîné
de la famille en relayant donc le
prétendant au trône de france chez barwa
en france en tous les cas ce serait vous
alors il ya un petit problème que je
peux tout de suite réglé j'ai dit
l'aînée de la famille d'orléans j'ai pas
dit l'aînée des capétiens car il ya un
autre prétendant au trône de france dont
le nom est louis 20 la branche aînée des
bourbons voilà la branche aînée des
bourdes s'est éteinte à la fin du 19e
siècle avec le comte de chambord bien
donc il fallait trouver d'autres
branches puisque c'est là la branche
aînée là c'est un alors il ya plusieurs
branches et deux branches il ya les
orléans vote branche avouent qu'ils
descendent d'un fils de louis xiii
il a beau ne l'appelez vieille manche
envie de l'appeler montabert
parce que les prend corps et c'est non
mais ça viendra à mon avis reid en
quatre sets première branche qui descend
d'un fils de louis xiii deuxième branche
les bourbons dit d'espagne qui
descendent d'un petit 6 de la cesap a
donc mais je m'en fous que ça me fait
plaisir en même temps c'est pas ça c'est
que j'essaye d'apprendre des trucs mois
donc ceux qui descendent du petit fils
de louis xiii
ils sont plus et n'est que vous bonne
pioche mauvaise pioche il y a eu une
petite erreur dans ce que vous dites
c'est qu'en france on descend par les
hommes
la légitimité ne peut se transmettre que
parlait jamais c'est de la merde en
espagne comme en espagne elle se
transmet par les femmes
ah oui vous dire que l'aîné des
capétiens espagnol descend par les
femmes dont kiel et ça marche pas quoi
sachant par un promu ouais voilà donc
vous êtes line et des capétiens
voilà seul problème si vous avez un
ancêtre qui s'est mal comporté à y en a
beaucoup
non mais vous êtes d'accord là dessus
tout à fait le lancer de monseigneur
philippe égalité vous avez tous à vous
philippe égalité l'essuyer pénalité où
il a voté la mort de louis saez son
cousin vous feriez l'amant de votre
cousin vous j'ai peint deux cousins j'ai
pas toujours mais je crois que si j'en
avais je tort
quand vous pourriez me faire chier 1
car les voitures y est d'abord de votre
cousin vous ça dépend ce qui m'a fait
boum auteur également de deux cousins
laurent j'adore mon cousin je peux voter
ça ou alors vous êtes d'accord autant
d'inégalités a voté la mort de oui c'est
vous la faire un grand seigneur bon sa
batterie pendant cinq minutes
non mais c'est vrai vous êtes d'accord
première première faute
deuxième faute en 1830 louis-philippe
vire son cousin encore était le frère de
louis seize chars le dise le viril
envoie à prague en exil lui prend son le
prends soin trop a fait pas tout à fait
magnéto serge nom lorsqu'il est lorsque
charles 17 partis parce qu'il la donne
il a donné les ordonnances ces fameuses
ordonnance et il a été chassé
gad apprend l'histoire de ton nouveau
pays on est allé chercher je luis filipe
pas deux fois de suite on peut dire
quand même que les orléans se sont mal
comportés avec la branche aînée oui bon
vous le reconnaissez d'ailleurs je sais
que vous le reconnaissez je sais que
vous le regrettez jeu les mêmes écrit
dit vous êtes né en 1933 en belgique
parce qu'à l'époque la famille royale
française était exilé depuis 1886 par la
troisième république parce qu'ils
avaient peur du retour du roi sur le
trône de france enseignants vous êtes
même vous êtes né la même année que jean
yanne ah oui très bonne année un bon
levier pc baptisé au jurançon vous non
oui oui comme henri iv avec de l'ail
avec de l'ail du jour ensemble et très
tôt monseigneur mesdames excusez moi
vous dit un truc genre c'est super
normal avec de l'ail way delahaye ok
c'est bon c'est nathan c'est notre as
quelque chose à inventer un langage chez
nos traditions à nous mais c'est votre
culture mais par émerger c'est notre
culture avec de la tendresse est vrai
les rois depuis henri iv les rois mais
expliqué ne puis henri iv roi
avec du jurançon qui est un an va
frotter delahaye des crucifiés des
gosses de carrément voilà delahaye et
puis et donc mon seigneur vous avez
souffert très tôt de la dureté de votre
père et votre frère nous en a parlé ici
même si on découvre dès le début du
bouquin l'éducation à laquelle vous avez
été soumise une éducation à ces sadiques
on pourrait dire parce que vous racontez
une scène terrible c'est quand votre
père vous voulez vous punir il venait
bienvenue envers lui il sortait comme ça
sa pochette
il a laissé tomber par terre et il
disait ramasse et c'est vrai que on a du
mal à le croire non mais à comprendre
comment quelqu'un de cette extraction
puisse se comporter d'une façon si
violente avec son fils serge entraygues
plus qu'à faire ramper un enfant comme
ça chaque paire est une méthode
d'éducation différentes
je trouve que mon père avait c'était de
cette méthode
moi ça me plaisait pas beaucoup parce
que à chaque fois c'est moi qui prenais
tous les coups dans la famille ouais
donc j'étais habitué ça c'est plus du
million qu'une tarte je trouve moi ça
fait moins mal quand même refrain trois
quarts d'heure de ceinture ans c'est pas
mal non plus et un événement je prends
la pochette
notre frère jacques d'orléans était
invité dans l'émission et avec jean
marie bigard et on parlait justement
comme vous venez de le voir de la dureté
du comportement de votre père avec vous
et vous dites vous-même d'ailleurs j'ai
beaucoup souffert du machiavélisme de
mon père j'ai pas dit du vin machiavelli
dans libération en 1999 monseigneur à
ardisson un monseigneur il a dès 1000 à
des fichiers n'est pas la peine d'en
sérieusement d'enseignants votre père
était très dure avec vous nos regards
vous nous dire pourquoi notre père c'est
maintenant continuer l'interro peut
parfois il vous a rien fait allez-y
c'est vrai que les îles à tignes très
sévère avec ses enfants mais disons que
c'était normal à ces époques la vie on
était onze enfants entrant enfants non
mais c'est vrai que dire des choses vous
être henri d'orléans devant tant de
dureté vous avez développé une surdité
psychologique qui n'a cessé qu'à l'âge
de 40 ans quand vous avez rencontré
votre deuxième femme et cas et là c'est
vrai c'est vrai bon vous avez vécu au
maroc étant petit ce qui vous rapproche
de gad elmaleh diary ensuite en espagne
ensuite au portugal c'est être un ballet
de pays en pays assez mal éduqué par un
père souvent absent et une mère sans
vouloir attenter à votre mère mais c'est
vrai un petit peu prise par le
tourbillon de la vie mondaine non
c'était plus tard ouais plus tard quand
elle était à paris
c'est normal elle avait des ailes avait
représenté la famille et donc fait
sciences po parce que le président
auriol accepte vous venir en france
faire vos études bien que votre famille
je le répète soient interdites jusqu'en
1950 votre famille il était interdit de
séjour en france guerre d'algérie vous
comportez fort brillamment croix de la
valeur militaire
mine de rien et là votre père vous
impose un mariage mais vous pouvez pas
vous opposer à ce mariage d'antan
carreau
n'était pas amoureux n'était pas un mot
j'ai des preuves on dirait ce qu'il en
pince monseigneur mais là non c'est vrai
que latéral la chance
j'accepte failli la faire aller on est
débarrassé on est tranquille catherine
demers qui les dissuade de tranquillité
le traîneau est ce que tu en penses 300
millions est-ce que monseigneur en pince
pour la duchesse d'york d'amberg voilà
bon c'est fait on est tranquille comme
ça au moins votre père dans mes blagues
à part quand même la monarchie s'est
basé sur l'hérédité principe dynastique
comment votre père qui était vraiment
monarchiste puisque c'est elle et n'est
donc d orléans
comment peut-il avoir passé sa vie à
vous vous dénigrez comme il l'a fait
vous et vos frères alors que il savait
bien voulu succès de riez de façon dans
la monarchie a pas de discussion oui bah
oui alors écoutez c'est un problème qui
doit régler avec lui-même et je peux pas
me mettre à sa place et donc vous êtes à
la région effectivement pendant cinq ans
ensuite vous lancer dans les affaires
fait des parfums et paul loup sulitzer
mais quand j'ai repris mon seigneur de
monter une affaire et paul loup sulitzer
c'est ça la question qui me brûlait
parce qu'ils ont un peu l'eau il peut
monter les affaires avec elle un portier
lyonnais il faut qu'ils monde des
affaires
c'est son truc à elle a fait des portes
clegg ça sentait bon
mais l'italie est fait avec le petit
carton j'ai travaillé trois ans avec des
avec année mais peut-être le nez des
bourbons et pensaient avoir hérité la
fameuse rue bourbon donc en 84 vous
épouser civilement à bordeaux micaela
cousino qu'une younès deleon qui donc
une roturière
malgré ce nom à rallonge non non elle
deschamps d'une grande d'espagne ah bon
non c'est un grand nom de l'espagne
avant donc c'est pourquoi votre père
vous en a voulu à mort pourquoi est-ce
que ça a déclenché les fans de la série
pourquoi parce que ils n'en voulaient
pas c'est donc là vous appeliez compte
de clermont et votre père vous appelle
compte de mortain dans mortagne à mort
il ya des daims je trouve
j'ai jamais connu ce conte de mortain
serpentant vous envoyer des lettres non
de comptes de mortain voulait renvoyer
en mettant inconnu à cette adresse
oui mais tu es quand même dur votre père
vraiment c'était son caractère ouais ça
existe beaucoup en france
voyons comme lui c'est allé très loin
l'histoire c'est à dire que c'est à dire
que votre père en 87 a décidé vous
n'était plus son héritier est une homme
votre fils jean ce qui est impossible
il vous happe ce n'était que je veux
dire que dans sa tête parce que c'est la
magie de finalement je vais entendre et
jolies jantes cdpa principe vous avez
demandé aux tribunaux de la république
de faire respecter les lois
fondamentales du royaume ce qui est
assez drôle quand ils sont dit
incompétent ouais et donc vous a été
rétablie héritiers en 1996 et votre
femme a été titré voilà donc la sphère
est rentré
leurs trois ans avant la mort de votre
père est rentré dans l'ordre il est mort
votre père à 90 ans en 1999
et vous dites effectivement sans
rencontre ce soir d'ailleurs espèce de
compassion vous avez pour lui vous dites
en dépit de tout et des heurts qui
m'opposait ramon père j'aimais le comte
de paris
évidemment son nom à l'époque et je le
pleure et c'est comme ça on aime un père
malgré toutes les vacheries qui peut
vous dire chrétien quand même à vous
toutes les méchancetés y en a fermé pour
éviter méchant comme sa dent dure et
orangina rouge
le parallèle non je ne sais pas vous
savez il ya des gens qui ont des
caractères très dur qui s'oppose à tout
justement il écoutait la valise rtl mais
vous qui vous savez vous avez raison
oui bien sûr mais c'est bien vous disiez
ça c'est qu'à la fin de sa vie votre
père vivait dans un vivait dans un
pavillon à chantilly avec monique frise
sa gouvernante capital pognon faut lire
la vérité et donc ils écoutent et la
valise rtl temps qu'elle passe la
serpillière
non mais c'est vrai je sais bien que je
raconterai pas du tout mais je trouve
hyper cultiver moisson et capétiens les
enlève surtout est ce que vous savez
alors que le vrai livre si j'étais bien
mais c'est faux je sais que j'ai fait du
dictionnaire tendrement est ce que vous
savez alors jean yanne
je crois que je regardais mon meilleur
élève ce soir d'où vous alors vraiment
voulait pas prendre ça se voit tout
juste que vous connaissez pas tout non
plus
la révolte est salée choix les jeunes
artistes graphiques ne dessine pas fait
mon portrait c'est bien c'est qu'il nous
fait penser à clotilde courau clotilde
courau excusez-moi monseigneur je
reviens vers vous mais clotilde courau
me disais que par amour elle était prête
elle avait embrassé cent fois les
chaussettes de son fiancé et je croyais
un grand seigneur je l'avais quoi en
brasse et 100 fois les chaussettes de
son fiancé clotilde courau je vous le
feriez caroline
ben voilà on peut revenir aux histoires
de la france et où on va continuer sur
l'histoire de france parce que gad
elmaleh ça m'intéresse de savoir comment
ça s'est passé
il débute maintenant l'une en arriver là
la femme de qui de nori de monseigneur
la mine à descendre de la montagne en
pyjama bien génial on va voir donc je
viens vous attendez moi j'ai janvier un
stage chez patience d'ailleurs je dis
rien de temps en temps jadis il chante
un come-back genre gens je m'adresse à
vous parce que vous êtes le sel ici
philippe le ray qui on peut avoir
attendu monseigneur le père de denrées
oui le comte de paris a toujours rêvé il
devait être roi et penser qu'elle est
roi il pensait que ce siècle allait être
celui de sa restauration
il a toujours essayé en 42 il part à
alger où on assassine halle d'arles en
lumière que je l'espère bien il va à
vichy voir pétain pour essayer de se
mettre bien avec pétain et pétales lui
propose deux ministères du
ravitaillement ce qui en pleine guerre
était pas une bonne affaire
ensuite il va voir de gaulle à un moment
de gaulle a été question votre père soit
présenté au suffrage universel patte de
gaulle en 65
j'aimerais c'est vrai vous savez ça oui
petite truie pour me faire plaisir je
sais bien sûr badauds tout les tous les
journaux tous les magazines
voilà bah dis lui des trucs vraiment dit
avant moi oui c'est sûr on sait bien que
de gaulle a maintenant à penser qu'il
pourrait rétablir la monarchie
voilà et ça s'est pas fait non et le
comte de paris on a cela rendue et gris
amer êtes d'accord là dessus on fait
clic et ça comme striée de gaulle a dit
content de paris pourquoi pas d'arène
les gitans et par un jour ça c'est
affligeant les mauvaise langues est
entouré le général ça c'est les
magazines people qui ont dit des
conneries rien c'est comme vous avec
donc qu'à la fin de l'émission a lâché
jusqu'à la fin donc si vous voulez
savoir si la star avec le gros gain de
sa les attendait la dernière minute de
l'émission mal à un gros poisson
c'est un gros poisson au level ou pas
alors non mais votre père il avait un
côté louis 15 un peu après moi le déluge
compris qu'ils n'ont pas laissé de
pognon quand même il aurait pu penser
quand même que vous vous allez vous
retrouver la prétendante besoin d'argent
pour vos tournées en province tout ça
pourquoi vous a pas laissé d'argent ça
fait de l'argent on en trouve toujours
en on me dit pas qu'on trouve toujours
attendait même pas toujours quand même
c'est comme il suffit de travailler un
peu près d'accord mais bon votre terre
est la vérité de d'un milliard de
nouveaux francs par 400 millions de
l'époque un milliard de nouveaux fronts
en 1940 à saint amand et master et à ton
et du pognon serait sérieusement en fait
qu'est ce que vous considérez que la
france est une start up
j'ai pas ici clans distincts qu'option
sur la fois rejetée si jamais ça marche
mais cimade là un président dont on a
tous des actions de la société france
c'est sur ces salles libéralisme dont il
va pas quand même la fortune d orléans
ça toujours été un truc énorme
votre père quand il quand il hérite en
42 du duc de guise il reçoit un milliard
de francs actuels quand il meurt et
reste rien du bourg est
ouais et alors là voilà est soupçonné on
y arrive est soupçonné à ce moment là la
gouvernante de votre père beau nick fry
est ce que vous connaissez gens
connaissent son nom j'en ai beaucoup
parlé dans des émissions sur des radios
périphériques vous avec monsieur baffie
nous aurions nous moquer d'un peu
d'huile après la pompe à fric à des
beaux-arts et puis vous connaissez bien
monique au mélange qu'on ne provient
menu jolie comme tout le monde les des
magazines sur le sur les têtes
couronnées et ceux qui le sont moins
ouais il était un peu moins elle passer
la serpillière pendant qu'ils écoutent
et la valise alors vous êtes prétendant
au trône de france aujourd'hui vous
vivez de vos livres votre peinture
oui vous avez pas votre premier tableau
il ya très longtemps 42 je tirais de
l'avenir la petite injection de 100 mg
achever pas sur place mais combien on
peut vendre cette tête de philippe hardy
sont dessinés et vous y êtes si
l'entraîneur niçois aujourd'hui
monseigneur je vis de mes livres de ma
peinture et de ma retraite de militaires
à la retraite d'office hier
dites moi vous êtes fait virer de la
petite ville à xavier là dans le 16 non
j'ai donné
mon congé parce que la ville de paris ne
vise pas ça ai dit ce que vous leur
devez 1 millions un peu moins ouais
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas payé le loyer
pendant dix ans j'avais pas l'argent
quand vous pensez quand on n'a pas
d'argent on paye pas y'a pas dû me fier
non mais attends t'es gentil mustapha il
paye pas et va en taule et lui on lui
dit rien d'accord j'ai bien compris il
ya deux poids et deux mesures parce
qu'il à mustapha et monseigneur qui
trône de france y est tour qui lui bien
elle m'a d'ailleurs dit inquiet tout
c'est normal
d'accord n'est pas et tout dans
sérieusement vous payez passé pendant
dix ans comme mouleur de 20 millions de
francs on ya eu quand même aussi de leur
côté ils ont un peu de laxisme sur
on laissait faire je pense qu'il ya
quand même pas mal dit pendant dix ans
un million de francs il va 10 millions
par an il ya deux mois mais ils valent
par mois ouais pour une maison comment
une grosse baraque à neuilly c'est que
tu ne lances une petite villa dans le
16eme pas cher dit m 90 mètres carrés
dans le xvième palace ils sont dire 59,3
leur bien et aujourd'hui alors voilà
c'est super chaud surtout ce soir vous
êtes dans un appartement dans un
immeuble dans le 15 à 5
vous faites vos courses à leur marché
moi ça m'amuse beaucoup de savoir que le
roi de france fait ses courses à leur
marché chez le chat l'endroit on
rencontre des gens et vous avez des
pages pour pousser votre caddie ou non c
c'est monseigneur au rayon crémerie brut
de 2 à 4 c c'est extraordinaire je
trouve ça c'est une image absolue
magnifiant logique de la france du
xxième siècle
monseigneur tout son caddie à l'europe
via les vous y allez venu mais je trouve
très sympathique et très normal des
libertés égalité le 16 il faisait bien
de la serrurerie mais c'est mal
enfin il y va lui-même mais y'a des
trucs à des mecs qui bossent pour loïc
deman seniors des trompettes et où serge
henri d'orléans croyez-vous après avoir
entendu tout ça que la famille d'orléans
puisse encore régné sur la france
ça ne dépend que des français on rallume
on va parler de votre livre maintenant
là laurent donner l'exemple à
monseigneur pas bougé pendant le jingle
non faire le petit malawite a pu
monseigneur il faut les expliqué bert
monseigneur ne fait pas les petites
mains pourquoi mon seigneur seigneur
monseigneur monseigneur monseigneur
grand seigneur
le programme
simplicité comme simplicité me touche
beaucoup ça va faire un carton t'as vu
dans l'émission comme monseigneur il a
fait les mains peintes à transformer
exactement bien alors votre livre
s'appelle le passeur de miroirs 7 aux
presses du châtelet
ça commence comme ça enfin c'est la page
9 je me souviens quand j'avais 5 ans mon
père possédait un manoir de granit gris
et j'ai appris un jour que je serais
peut-être roi ce livre c'est un peu
qu'est ce qu'être un roi un à travers un
conte philosophique initiatique
si vous avez choisi ce style de conte
philosophique en rapport avec les
lettres persanes avec des choses comme
ça parce que vous reprochez l'époque
d'avoir un langage trop aseptisé c'est
ça ouais nous sommes dans le
politiquement correct et moi j'aime la
liberté la liberté d'expression et donc
c'est la seule façon d'avoir une
certaine liberté c'est de prendre de
cette forme de conte philosophique
la visite que l'époque moderne l'homme
enfin l'individu a un peu perdu son âme
et vous n'êtes pas pour un retour en
arrière vous n'êtes pas fatigués que
j'ai eu tellement à lutter contre votre
père toute façon qu'on peut penser que
vous avez quand même un certain sens de
la liberté même s'ils voulaient pas le
dire parce que vous respectez votre
perte ce qui est normal mais c'est vrai
que vous avez un certain sens de la
liberté aux états pour un retour en
arrière vous n'êtes pas quelqu'un de
réactionnaire n'est pas quelqu'un de
conservateurs d'ailleurs on peut dire
que les orléans à leur décharge après
tout ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
les anglais ont toujours été très
libéraux et ben rapport aux par rapport
à la branche aînée au bond de la branche
aînée
les jantes et même parfois à la pointe
du progrès parce que
souvient que sous
louis saez sont d'abord les orléans
clients qui ont eu les premiers vaccins
pour la paris absolument
mais c'est quoi les châteaux que qu'ils
ont eue parce que j'ai envie d'un jour
d'aller dans un château et dire moi je
le connais le mec qui mais c'est vrai il
ya des châteaux vous avez joué plein de
château d'amboise s'avoue amboise encore
c'était ça vous encore moins ok moi je
peux venir de votre part ces gav way
s'est gâté c'est monseigneur qui va dit
avec la caravane tendresse qu'il nous
fait pleurer avec la situation
dramatique du mec qui a le château
d'amboise je ne gagne pas à maintenant
ils appartiennent à une fondation
oui c'est nous mais les gens visitent
mais c'est comme chantilly monseigneur
scom chambily mais bon chantier voila
c'est une fondation lieutenant ils ont
donné des trucs gentils votre votre père
mais aussi à sa décharge a quand même
fait beaucoup pour les personnes âgées
donc vous êtes vous n'êtes pas comme je
disais vous n'êtes pas très conservateur
vous n'êtes pas pour un retour en
arrière
vous êtes vous appelez ça une écologie
divine c'est quoi une écologie divine
nous sommes entourés par quand même une
nature que nous n'avons pas créé ce
quelqu'un d'autre qui l'a créé et il
faut la respecter donc je dis qu'il faut
savoir respecter toutes ces lois de la
nature
regardez tout ce qui se passe maintenant
et c'est marrant parce que plus j'écoute
et plus ça m'intéresse
vous pensez quoi qu envoyé l'espagne qui
est l'exemple d'une monarchie qui marche
bien ou le maroc
ou quand vous voyez l'angleterre la
hollande la suède la norvège et un
franco monsieur pendant il fallait y
aurait fallu non mais sérieusement vous
pensez quoi qu'on est toutes ces
monarchies européennes parce que je
crois qu'en europe si la moitié des pays
de l'europe qui sont des monarchies vous
pensez quoi
ça pourrait marcher en france où la
france est définitivement cuit non je
pense que toute solution est à envisager
un jour parce que regarder actuellement
la droite la gauche c'est un peu blanc
bonnet bonnet blanc
lundi il faut il faut supprimer les
farines loterie dit dis qu'on va
permettre les ogm
bon on va dans une une société
complètement folle alors il faut un jour
mettre un peu d'ordre dans tout cela
ouais bon je vois que il ya un certain
ordre en espagne il y en a un en
angleterre il y en a en belgique
au maroc je connais bien au genre de
droit que je trouve très haut et c'est
m6 ben oui j'ai déjà aux cadors m-66
bien il va vous arriver un truc terrible
à monseigneur là
[Musique]
ah c'est pas moi qui ait bougé
monseigneur atteint des sommets de la
médium et héritier aloïs cailleau
staline pourquoi staline passant alors
je suis là je suis scié la préfet
restait l'une pourquoi parce qu'il a tué
plus de gens quittent leur nom parce
qu'il a essayé de sortir la russie de là
où elle était c'est fou parce que jean
claude gayssot était la semaine dernière
il est communiste ministres communistes
du gouvernement et il a dit ni l'un ni
l'autre
enfin laura la france à 1 comment ça se
fait parce qu'ils ont beso à 10 mois
ni l'un ni l'autre et voir l'héritier du
d orléans me répondent de staline je
suis scotché là alors est-ce que vous
préféreriez vous réincarner écoutez bien
mon seigneur est-ce que vous préféreriez
voir incarner ans louis saez louis 17
louis xviii
la réincarnation et quelque chose à
laquelle je crois c'est vrai et je vous
dirai c'est que nous y 7 n'a pas
accompli tout ce qu'il avait à accomplir
donc peut-être qu'il vaut mieux que je
ne me réincarner en loup 17
est-ce que vous préféreriez être
palestinien à gaza indien en amazonie ou
chrétiens à beyrouth alors je choisis le
chrétien beyrouth
ouais bon c'est que c'est le sort le
plus enviable des trois noms c'est le
plus difficile c'est plus difficile
jeudi c'est le plus difficile oui c'est
votre côté christique non c'est le côté
challenge
si vous deviez avoir quelque chose en
plus mon seigneur voudriez avoir un nez
un oeil un doigt ou un sexe en plus un
oeil un hâle tous là imaginez vous ayez
commis un crime monseigneur acquis
demanderiez vous de vous aider à cacher
le corps à mon épouse
ouais vous faites pas tu es quelqu'un
pour vous aider un pour cacher le corps
dans les cantines scolaires cantine
scolaire il ya des énormes a remis les
mômes ils savent pas ce qui marche c'est
vrai c'est vrai on rajoute un peu de
purée séjour
bien avec qui passeriez-vous le plus
volontiers la nuit c'est un jeu de
l'esprit a évidemment bien entendu avec
anne sinclair leur sac
je n'aime pas mon seigneur anne sinclair
je connais pas les deux autres lors
sinclair c'est une star de films un
petit peu pourquoi aujourd'hui
hall est une amie de rocco ou bob
sinclair tant qu'à faire je préfère la
première anne sinclair très bien vous
faites des petits jeux pour josiane vous
pouvez choisir les kivu entre laure
sinclair anne sinclair ou bob sinclair
alors c'est un clair je la connais je
les rencontre et les alarmes yade water
maintenant et en ligne en mai sous la
super classe reine sinclair ça c'est
anne sinclair aussi à la wii ou non lors
lors d'accord qui échouent les jeux
footon comme ça
quel bonheur bien alors monseigneur on
se concentre la bombe atomique arrive
dans 5 minutes vous faites quoi
je continue à faire ce que j'ai à faire
sa venue qu'il peut faire des coques n'a
pas le temps non mais c'est vrai vous
vous continuez
ben oui on part en poussière dans cinq
minutes
ouais je continue à faire ce que je
payais n'aient pas de réflexe de prier
peut-être que je suis en train de déjà
pris dernière question monseigneur votre
punition préféré le fouet de punition
préféré monseigneur est ce que vous
préférez être peint ces mordus ou pique
est ainsi passée caroline préférez quoi
maintenant pincez mordu ou piquer ils
tremblent même temps un cocktail
explosif à la la
là
et voilà
henri d'orléans sera revenu sur le trône
de france ça sera la chanson qui
remplacera la marseillaise les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus